unvorstellbar wenn man dann mitbekommen
dass man neben so jemanden gewohnt hatte
wir haben uns im haus bei nachbarn
umgehört wie würden sie ihren nachbarn
beschreiben als ruhigen ist briten
folgen man kann auch gar nicht anders
also das ist nie aufgefallen wenige
haben sie engeren kontakt zweck gehabt
nur wenn wir pakete für ihn angenommen
haben aber ansonsten nur während nun
vorgenommen sie wohnt direkt über ihnen
hat er sich irgendwie bemerkbar gemacht
meine kleine feier keine oder andere
macht man doch häufiger wenn daraufhin
die bisher noch überhaupt nicht gehört
können sie sich vorstellen was er getan
hat getan haben so immer passt überhaupt
nicht in das bild wo sich immer mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren